таку картину Цієї зими нерідко можна
було побачити в Києві українська столиця
та інші міста поринали у темряву після
масованих обстрілів Росією
енергооб'єктів Однак до квітня Україна
досягла таких помітних успіхів у
відновленні інфраструктури що вперше за
півроку починає експортувати
електроенергію в інші країни вже майже
два місяці енергосистема працює без
обмежень споживачів
найскладнішу зиму пройдену наступний
крок відкриття експорту електроенергії
Що дозволить залучити додатковий
фінансовий ресурс для необхідної
відбудови знищеної та ремонту
пошкодженої енергетичної інфраструктури
Герман Галущенко міністр енергетики
України
відбувся український енергетики вдалися
до низки нестандартних методів кажуть у
міністерстві завдяки цьому пошкодження
вдалося відновити набагато швидше усіх
секретів не розкривають але один з них
коли перед обстрілом працівники
енергосистеми розвантажували потенційне
місце удару і завдяки цьому завдавалося
менше збитків системи в цілому крім того
українські енергетики нерідко ризикували
життям аби швидше відремонтувати
пошкоджені лінії та підстанції а нестачі
потужностей що виникла після окупації
запорізької АЕС вдалося компенсувати за
рахунок завершення ремонту Рівненської
атомної електростанції на думку
більшості експертів з питань енергетики
рішення про експорту українського струму
виправдане
що ми зможемо
вид країна експортер цього року через
війну через процес відновлення але в
будь-якому випадку я вважаю що це добре
ініціатива яку Європа має підтримати
знову ж таки був в майбутньому я думаю
ми зможемо забезпечити Європу більшою
кількістю електроенергії та енергетичною
безпекою для тих європейських країн яким
все ще потрібно більше електроенергії
за оцінками експертів нині в Україні
справді виробляється достатньо
електроенергії споживання струму після
російського вторгнення зменшилося на
30%. по-перше припинили роботу великий
підприємства споживачі струму зокрема
зруйновані комбінати в Маріуполі
по-друге мільйони українців виїхали за
кордон тож нині Україна виробляє більше
струму ніж споживає водночас експерти
зазначають що період експорту
української електрики буде
короткостроковим і не зможе тривати
цілий рік
по-перше нам потрібно відновити
інфраструктуру по-друге все ще триває
війна тому Росія все ще завдаватиме
збитків і по-третє ми повинні
підготуватися до наступної зими крім
того будуть інші процеси зокрема атомним
електростанціям потрібно буде виконувати
деякі роботи з технічного обслуговування
тож якщо в Україні є можливість не
просто брати гроші а заробляти гроші це
непогана опція
пережити важку зиму Україні допомогли
також європейські партнери так
синхронізація з європейською мережею
допомогла українській енергосистемі
залишатися стабільною та уникати великих
системних аварій не варто забувати її
про поліпшення роботи української
системи ППО більшість ракет та Дронів
вдається збивати енергооб'єкти з кожним
місяцем та далі надійніше захищені
військовий експерт і констатують поразку
стратегії кремлян Ані знищити
енергосистему Ані зламати волю українців
до боротьби Росії не вдалося
стратегічна повітряна кампанія
метаударів по інфраструктурі полягала в
тому що підірвати волю українського
народу до боротьби очевидно Якщо вам
взимку холодно то ви замерзнете зими
підривають моральний дух але Росії цього
не вдалося зробити майже всі
спостерігачі та експерти передбачали що
цей план провалиться адже дуже важко
знищити державну інфраструктуру
електропостачання без достовірної
інформації та дуже точного потрапляння в
ціль але й українці показали себе
надзвичайно стійкими їм вдалося легко
полагодити пошкодження тож з боку Росії
це була марна трата боєприпасів і
Оскільки ми вступаємо в літню пору
проблема холодних і темних ночей більше
не актуальна
російський обстріли пошкодили понад 50
відсотків енергетичної інфраструктуру
України на її відновлення за
найскромнішими оцінками програми
розвитку ООН потрібен мільярд доларів
тим часом українські енергетики
готуються до нових обстрілів та
наступної зими завдання № 1 захистити
найважливіший об'єкти очікується Що
частину їх розміщуватимуть під землею що
зробить їх недосяжними для російських
ракет у Києві сподіваються що експорт
української електроенергії допоможе
Європі позбутися залежності від
російського газу а в Україні накопичують
кошти на підготовку до опалювального
сезону